ask you go back to the moment you're
told you're going to play Lear what is
the first set of things you do the first
set of things I did was to find out the
hours that elderly people could use the
pools in my local swimming pool because
I was really scared that I didn't have
either the physical or the vocal
strength for it and so I used to get up
every morning walk down the hill to the
swimming pool and there is a big kind of
Olympic sized pool and then there's the
smaller one which is where they teach
children to swim but the elderly and the
disabled are allowed to use it from 7:00
until 9:00 and so I would get in the
pool with my fellow elderly swimmers and
it was really marvelous it was like a
kind of elderly United Nations just I
mean there we are when we'd be jumping
away and swimming and walking and it was
great so that was the first thing to get
myself physically in shape as I thought
because it's a group it's a grueling do
you know what's really fascinating about
it but this is true for all I think
great plays and there's no question this
is a great great play there is an energy
in these plays and if you manage to tap
into that it just carries you along like
a kind of jet playing or something and
if that is extraordinary and very unique
and when you touch that energy is it do
you go back to your old copy of Lear do
you get a brand new copy it's not
something that it could in a curious
kind of way it obviously comes out of
the written word but that energy is
dependent on everybody in the play it's
not a separate experience it's we are
all responsible for the whole play
whether the part is large or small and
I'm tapping that energies when we're all
able to do it without you know saying
you know turn the switch on it's your
turn I mean it just happens you've said
that you can't survive with an ego on
the stage is that why because it's a
group well it was one of the things the
first things that I was taught when I
was
being regularly employed I mean my great
sort of breaks who was working for Peter
Brooke who's probably the greatest
theatrical director there's a really old
century and he works always from the
basis that the total is greater than the
sum of the parts
that means everybody and is there a
production to be found and he expects
everybody to help him on that
exploratory trip and so the first thing
you had to leave outside the rehearsal
room door he was your ego because
there's no place of that one of the
shocking things for me when I was a
member of parliament was I saw these
people going up and down the corridors
of Parliament with egos which would not
be tolerated for 30 seconds in a
professional theatre and just wouldn't
and look at what we're doing now I mean
what has happened to these people
anyway now what do you mean by that well
I'm thinking about our particular
struggle with brexit at the moment where
the country is voted to leave the
European Union and obviously it's not
being covered as extensively here in
America as it's being covered in my
country but you do get television
reportage from the chamber of the House
of Commons and I sit there and I look at
these people and I know them and I've
worked with them and I think well I
can't swear but I would like to what has
happened to you what are they do they
think they're doing because they're
doing nothing and if we crush out of
Europe well you know what is going to
happen to our economy in that country
and it's just musing and bewildering to
me do you find yourself wanting to
address the right honourable gentleman
and and revert back to your no I
wouldn't want to be there I mean I'm in
that happy position where I can sit
outside and just [ __ ] at them which I
do but I do think the way our Prime
Minister has been treated both by her
own party and obviously mine but also by
in the sense the political journalism in
my country at the moment there she is
slogging away the owe me as somebody
said to me the only adult in the room as
far as we're concerned and she's being
treated abominably and she still
is trying to deliver of the country has
told our Parliament they want to happen
I don't agree with the country but
nonetheless that's the Democratic
decision and the country tol spoke with
that voice but that was not necessarily
her position so she's carrying out
something that she knows no no I mean
she's a Romania as I am a remainder but
her job as the Prime Minister of the
country is to deliver what the country
has told Parliament it wants to happen
to us I think they're wrong but
nonetheless that's the Democratic
decision I read that you said you saw a
brexit coming ten years before it Oh a
long time before that actually because
the underlying problem
well reason I think and it's not
exclusive to pregnant you see it being
exhibited across the whole of Western
Europe and that is immigration the the
rest of the world being you know and
these people flooding into Europe to
live I mean let's face it they're not I
mean their own countries can provide
them with nothing but death and
destruction but that was I think is the
basic reason for this and people simply
you know I would get from when I was
still a member of parliament my
constituents complaining about
immigration and you know their kids
couldn't get into the schools they
wanted their kids couldn't get the
houses the NHS was being crucified none
of those things have anything really to
do with immigration or certainly being
part of Europe they were the exclusive
responsibility of the British government
of the day so when in my opinion
mistakenly Mr Cameron introduced
referendum people used the free movement
of people's which is one of the basic
principles of the European Union as a
reason why their own lives were not as
they wanted them to be and that's one of
my reasons my interpretations of where
we are where we are tell me what advice
surgery is it's something that all
members of parliament hold I used to
hold one every week in in different
parts of my
constituency but always pretty much in
the same place in those different parts
and you go long in the afternoon it was
always Friday afternoon Saturday morning
for me and your constituents come to see
you and they have problems and things of
that nature and it was so revelatory for
me that because someone would come into
that room never seen them before in my
life they didn't know me and they would
lay their life out on the table in front
of you and they come to you because nine
times out of ten the member of palm
which is the court of last resort and
the other thing that was so humbling
actually you would do your best
obviously to try and help them and
sometimes you got the result that they
wanted and sometimes you didn't but they
all always said thank you that you know
amazing you talked about egos and acting
in one point I read you said that you
have to stay in touch with people and
the regular nosov life too with acting
is that the case it makes you good
Member of Parliament does it make you a
good actor
well I wouldn't I don't know well I
think I don't whether it made me a good
member of parliament it's very again
revelatory when you want to be a member
of parliament you know the shoe is very
much on the voters foot and they know
where to place it if they're so inclined
I don't know I mean I in a way I feel
I'm blessed in as much as the the
socio-economic group I come from was it
was very simple if you didn't work you
didn't eat and so I have been blessed
with a strong work ethic and I valued
that very moving tell me about your
parents because you learned that from
them well for example my father who I
think went to see when he was 12 and
[Music]
obviously there was the war when he was
in the Navy and then when he came back
he was bricklayer and my mother I'm the
eldest of four daughters and you know
she was the mum of four for door
and when during the water of course when
all the guys went I mean the women ran
everything they and then when the war
was over they were told go away it's
okay find the men who come back oh
really
anyway but I was very fortunate in that
respect in that we lived very close
certainly to well both my paternal and
maternal grandparents and so there was
that supportive family around I mean
when I went off to do my audition
hopefully to get a place at RADA which I
did which is the Royal Academy of
Dramatic Art my mother thought she was
never good to see me again because I'd
be sold to white slavers you know I mean
it was that kind of a very close family
in a very anyway a close community mean
there was nothing that I or my sisters
could have got away with I mean for
instance if we decided we didn't want to
go to school that day within 30 seconds
my mother would have known that because
somebody was essential hey Joe I've just
seen your girls walking down the street
while there's school oh they're not well
or something boom you know big explosion
and you carry that into your work today
that ethic I think I mean well yeah I
mean usually I mean you haven't done it
and I hope you won't because I'm gonna
give you a warning here you know it
interviewers will tell you about the
play is it fun are you enjoying it and
my immediate responses it's work
what do you mean it's work when I think
of all those years that I pursued work
and didn't get it yeah you are so at one
point said if you have anything left
after a performance you haven't done it
right absolutely view you take anything
home then why have you take me to home
the place to leave it is the stage yeah
absolutely
which means at the end of a show you are
feeling what well oddly still very
energized I mean my worst day is my day
off when I feel absolutely wasted and
that's because they you know the the
kind of the whole we talk about dr.
theatre I think
true because it you know exactly where
you have to be you know what your duty
is it's not that you know exactly you
don't in a funny kind of way I mean for
me every performance is the first
performance and I think that's true
I put certainly most of the actors I
know and you have to find it then you
can't you know it's not it's not so
you've got in your pocket and you could
take it out a little package and I'm
rapping say to me what nazir why is the
old in you know here's the perf here's
the play you have to find it so
terrifying every every night I did a
play with a wonderful artist called Mona
Washburn and we did this play she played
my aunt in his play and she was in her
late sixties early seventies of it and
every performance at the play opened
when the curtain went up she was sitting
on the sofa I was sitting on the chair
and every performance she would sit and
look sofa and she would say please God
let me die
please God let me die please God let me
die the curtain went up boom and there
she was just superb oh yeah we are
sadomasochists I've decided you know we
do it but we torture ourselves at the
same time and is that the only way it
can be as good as it is I'm well I
wouldn't want to go that far I mean
because you know actors are all
individuals I mean we're not carbon
copies of each other
but it would worry me if I wasn't
frightened yeah it really would
cuz writers are the ones who think
they're the ones who are the
sadomasochists who have the hard life
well it's a lonely life I'm sure I still
don't know why contemporary dramatist
find women so boring they never write
seemed to me a play where a woman is the
sensual dramatic engine but we live in
hopes mind you I've been hoping and and
so as you were coming up as an actress
what what what kind of drama school the
then director of the Drama School who
was himself a very very very good
theatrical director said to me I was
then what 20 he said to me don't expect
to work much before you're 40 because
you're essentially
character actress and that was very
accurate miniaturization of what British
theater was like at that time it was
still pretty much a theater in which you
had male and female it was essentially
middle class I think but then of course
the whole of British theater change
because John Osborne Road looked back in
anger and suddenly accents other than
received pronunciation where permissible
people that didn't have kind of safe
lives in that way and of course
television also began to exert not a
hold but open up new doors for
dramatists and that's where you know
it's a good timing as far as I was
concerned you talked about the
sadomasochism of acting talked about
what it was like going to all of those
calls for actors in those well I never
ever got a job from the audition and the
you know you'd walk in and they'd look
at you you'd prepared yourself and
they'd say oh sorry darling you're too
tall too short you're blonde you're
brown whatever whatever new out you
would go and that to begin with that
sense of read a personal rejection is
very powerful and very upsetting but
over time you realize that it isn't
personal
and then yeah you know I was very
fortunate I had a lot of luck this to me
has always been a paradox and you can
solve it for me which is on the one hand
you have to give everything in a
performance you have to be emotionally
available Meryl Streep says your pores
have to be open to the audience all of
that vulnerability and then you go
through auditions like that and it's I
don't know how how one can be both well
you are I mean you can and you do I mean
obviously time and experience help there
but I mean to look at the positive side
of it I mean well I'm I'm obviously from
England all that in the main it's myth
that were totally socially [ __ ] and
take
forever to get to know anyone English
isn't true but there is a kind of
pattern of behavior that is that you go
through when you meet people you know
socially you don't have time for that
with actors you have to go and we all do
you go to a level which is below that
you may loathe each other but it doesn't
really determining that you have to find
that others source which is which is the
character and the character you're
working with in them and that kind of
thing and that's amazing why do British
audiences not - standing ovations and
Americans do what we do now I told him
off words wasn't about any performance
but I do open my big mouth too much
sometimes I don't know I mean but then
you see when I'm the very first play I
did here in New York I came with the
Royal Shakespeare Company and was it
1970 and it was the short title is the
Mara saga which had been a big success
in London and when we dumb at play in
London with the Royal Shakespeare
Company we had played it this was every
performance without a sound from the
audience until they went crazy again no
standing ovations I didn't know I'd been
you know they applauded we do our first
performance here in New York and it was
played that her music in it and songs so
first son goes through Bravo encore
encore what what we were getting laughs
we were getting yes very dead silences
but we all came off that's dancing what
the play we're doing what the play we're
doing what what are we doing here
because American audiences are so
immediate in their responses and and in
a way I think it's I find it very not
always marvelously helpful but helpful
because in a funny kind of way they want
you to know they're there and they it's
not I mean and then di the best
theatrical performances are always when
you know you've got
all those strangers sitting in the dark
and then strangers coming from the light
and energy goes from the light to the
dark and if it works
that energy is returned to you and so it
goes throughout the night and if it
really works it's a kind of model for me
of an ideal Society you know that that
shared and strengthened so is it that
the play doesn't exactly take place on
the stage it takes place in some space
between the stage and the audience oh
well I would know ideally that space
isn't there I mean there is obviously
that kind of space because there's a
respect on both sides
we don't have footlights anymore - yeah
I mean if that's something else it's
gone but I mean there is that hopefully
there is that kind of respect which he
shared between the two but when the play
really works it is it is a unique and
powerful experience you were talking
earlier about the feeling that you're
doing it for the first time well we are
told ians buffet
if the olivier story of him going back
is that a true story well I've heard it
so many times and I see no reason to
doubt it it what is extraordinary in
many ways is it was when he was doing a
cellar when the National Theatre was
still at the Old Vic had moved to its
present building and the play had been
in the repertoire for some time but this
particular night he was being
particularly brilliant an extent you
know the actors were in danger of
missing their cues because they didn't
want to leave the wings to see what he
was doing the audience of course goes
crazy at the end and everybody he's
heard swearing breaking up his dressing
room
and eventually somebody said well you
know we've got to find out what's wrong
so they sent the youngest ASM probably
to knock honey's so she knocks on the
door bless her and Gunn she goes in and
she said don't think you know and we
were really rather worried because you
were absolutely marvelous and he said I
know but I don't know why and
there you have it why this night is
every other night every night
tell me about power as you saw it in
politics and as you see it in the play
it's difficult to make a direct analogy
there because the power that is in the
play of King Lear is at a time where
democracy was not anything that anybody
thought about I mean power was passed
down bloodlines or it was taken by
murderous events as far as King Lear is
concerned he has inherited his country
he's a man who no one has ever said no
to in his entire life which is the
reason for the tragedy unfolding the
power of being a member of parliament is
myth really because as an individual you
don't have that power you have a power
on behalf of other people I mean
certainly as a member of parliament for
a constituency and your constituent we
talked about our advice surgeries come
to you with problems your letters will
be answered people will respond to your
phone calls as I've said you don't
always get the result that the
individual wanted but a sense of
personal individual power is simply not
the case
and one of the the powerful things
actually about being in Parliament is
when that sense expresses itself less in
the votes because they're always well
aware they're not only more predictable
over a specific piece of legislation or
even when you're you know in a committee
examining a bill line by line you pretty
much know how things are going to swing
because it's embedded in a party
political manifesto which you you know
campaigned on to hopefully get your
party into power but there of course is
that power which is
I was about to say outside Parliament
itself it isn't at the moment because we
have a very I mean John per burqa is a
man who is firm believer he's the
speaker in the part in affording
backbench MP s the opportunity to action
question the government of the day and
also he's been very innovative in
changes to the actual place itself to
encourage and make easier you know the
population of the United Kingdom to
actually get into their Parliament but
the exercise of power in that sense is
not something that one has any real
sense of being and I mean even when I
was the lowest form of ministerial life
when removing government in the
Department of Transport that was not a
sense that I had until it was one
airline I can't remember it was which we
had as a country said no you've got to
do this before we let you land again and
we'd received the deputations all that
kind of thing
and I said well and when all that if
they were mmm they seemed to make a very
good case of into my personal secretary
who was appointed from the civil service
and didn't come from the body said to me
well yeah but you know if he crashes
it's all down to you that kind of wakes
you up a bit yes none of the power and
all of the responsibilities in this yeah
you got into politics to push back
against Margaret absolutely did you feel
like it when you were done with your
political career that you had achieved
what you set out to do well in as much
as we we're in government from 97 for
you know three sessions but take for
example one of the things that really I
mean it still makes me furious was she
introduced the idea that you could buy
your council flat your social housing if
you live there certain number of years
it wasn't usually at a price way below
the mark
value great so we're now looking at the
situation where it is absolutely
impossible nine times out of ten but the
people I mean I'm usual under than as an
example for most metropolitan city in my
country where it's virtually impossible
for the people who make those cities run
to find a a home they can afford to rent
a million miles away from home they can
afford to buy and it all stems from that
and I'm not excluding my own party from
criticism here because even my murmuring
government although we did increase the
amount of building for what we call
social housing in that sense it
certainly doesn't meet the need and so
now we're seeing yet again you know
people sleeping on the streets and all
that kind of stuff and the basic view
that she had of what was the way forward
for my country was to me total anathema
she said once what the suffragettes ever
do for me hang on go you know that
there's no such thing as a society I
think there is and I think it's a duty
all of us try to make their societies
work and function properly and we get on
together are you optimistic about the
wheel of society that it tends always
towards positive or negative I think it
goes round certainly I mean I'm looking
at Western European democracies and I
wonder one well a look at my own country
no wonder what we're doing and I wonder
what they're doing and at a time when it
seems to me the world should be
concentrating more and more on how we
communicate well with each other we are
basically the same envelopes you know
human beings cut me and I bleed to
misquote I and you know this this idea
that something is achieved by separating
or putting up barriers or I just don't
get that and I hope yes that the world I
look towards the younger generations to
say no look where we're going is not
right and that's one of the interesting
things about the
Claire I mean I mean he is the most
contemporary journalist there is but you
know we have a lot in my country about
Millennials so the younger generation or
they're looking at their future and
they're saying you know it's not gonna
be like what's repair ins and he's
hanging in his play there's a young guy
saying we only get the money when
they're dead and then we're too old to
enjoy it and you think I'm gone I know
Justin you said Shakespeare really asks
three questions absolutely who are we
what are we why are we and no one's come
up with sufficiently comprehensive
answers so I suppose we lolled keep on
masking those questions you mentioned
how playwrights are not writing roles
for women what roles are being written
for women in politics I think there has
been a major shift there in many ways
but if I look at the example of my own
country for example the prospective
parliamentary candidate the person you
choose in your constituency party I
think certainly the Labour Party said
that they have to be you know women
candidates obviously the Liberal
Democrats have as well conservatives a
kind of a bit on on the fence about it
but it has to really start at that kind
of grassroots level I know when we there
they've already introduced the idea of
all women candidates for prospective
parliamentary candidate a lot of the
constituency parties were outraged and
so a lot of sent out you know saying
look this is a comparatively good idea
very good idea and the constituencies
that I went to they all said the same
thing that they had never seen
candidates of such equal ability as the
old women short lists because you know
it was like everything was the old boys
network you know oh he's in the next one
up the ladder and they were really
surprised by that and that's very
positive I think and we are seeing more
and more women around the world not just
in Western European democracies but
there are still there's a basic basic
I think gate that yet has to be opened
and that is that women can not like each
other
I mean actively positively dislike each
other but they can't sit around a table
and concentrate on a problem that
requires solution and come up with a
solution I remember when I was first
elected didn't there would be these
committees
I mean 92 more women elected that year
than ever before
will you be on the committee and there'd
be but three token women and nine others
are all guys and I can't remember what
we were discussing this particular day
but one of my colleagues put female
colleagues put forward this idea and old
guys went oh yeah very interesting
ten minutes later one of the guys came
up with the same idea and they all said
oh that's very good my colleague he said
not the one who put the ad oh hang on a
minute she said that ten minutes ago and
you saw all these faces going on there
below women don't they drive you mad
lots of things in those kinds of areas
we have to change the most fundamental
is get out and vote I mean that's the
thing get out and vote you talked about
how women could be on opposite sides but
they come to an agreement Lee in America
there is extraordinary polarization
people who believe have different
ideologies cannot talk to each other you
have a son who's a conservative well yes
he is when he told me I'm I mean he's a
political journalist and certainly the
newspaper that he writes for is further
to the right the knife wouldn't feel
comfortable with but in a funny kind of
way what am I trying to say here I mean
I did say it when he told me well I'm
gonna have to well I said that about
brakes as well I'm gonna have to make
emigrate then but of course I didn't but
it is possible still within the context
of our family to have discussions with
job poles apart but then that's been my
experience with him all my life I mean
he's always
the mind observe and you know things
like that what does amaze me is people I
know well who I mean and in case the
breaks it deal that's done it they
cannot speak to other members of their
family and you think my god I mean you
know because there's simply no meeting
minds on I don't where we're going but
what do you make of people who want to
compare bring down Trump into a
conversation about Lear Jack but but
people who see Donald Trump or when they
were watching Lear they think they think
of the clear isn't right on the Trump he
doesn't he has no self-pity he doesn't
really have fear he's basically honest
he has a strong sense of responsibility
where he's flawed is that he as I say no
one ever said to him no and they tell me
towards the end of his life that he
simply realizes and and it frankly
admits it you know I'm not perfect he
doesn't use those words Shakespeare used
far better language than I do but no no
there's no similarity there I mean
there's a difference between an a sense
of absolute power which he does have and
ego mania he's he's not in that sense an
ego mania think I mean it just amazes
him that you know it's almost a sin to
ask this question but did with a play of
this size and scope but what does Lear
mean to you at its center I have to
approach it starting to go back to my
advice surgery days but one of the
requirements duties responsibilities but
one of the things that was most
interesting was visiting old people's
homes day centers things of that nature
and as we get older we are I mean as a
species living much much longer than our
parents for example did those absolutes
boundaries
those barriers which define our genders
begin to fray they begin to crack they
begin to get a bit misty and that I
think is what I have found in a new
curious kind of way most useful in doing
Lear is is that he he does begin to go
down that path I mean some of the
emotions that he's probably never
thought about I mean the most clearest
one for me is where he castigates
himself for not taking care of the poor
I mean he's just probably the first time
in his life admits failure and and it's
painful I mean it really hurts it and so
that I found I want to go back again and
ask you about this the fact that women
are not written for why what do we think
that is I don't know I find it very
curious and I've been finding it curious
really for a very very long time because
I see no market change in that why there
have been enormous changes in women's
lives
some of them great something not so
great and there is still room I'm not
arguing that we are by any means equal
because we're not but there have been
major strides made and yet contemporary
dramatists it seems to me still don't
find women interesting as characters we
are rarely if ever the central dramatic
engine and when I put up this moon
before people say oh no no you know
there are lots of women writers no no
come on it always is it still remains
that if a woman is successful whatever
she chooses to do she is the exception
that proves the rule if she fails well
we told you they were all failures and
that basic untruth I don't see
fracturing or cracking or becoming
frayed around the edges as far as
contemporary dramatists against
and it puzzles me I don't know where
they find a Subaru
have you ever thought about writing well
I couldn't write a postcard I swear to
you I couldn't why I don't know I mean
my brain I like to think my brain moves
too quickly and my hand can't catch up
but I'm sure that isn't true
because when I have said that people say
to me well then record it and I said
then I'd be talking to myself we all
know what that's the first I know is
leer in your head as a character during
the day on your day off say are you in
touch with I wouldn't say as a character
no but there is always something that
says are you but not eat that in case
you should you know or no no you can't
have a drink and all I had stuff there
is that sense of responsibility for the
envelope that he's going to hopefully
find there to be as good as it can be
but you know it's as I said earlier I
mean we are all responsible for this
play and in the kind of curious way I am
as dependent upon all the characters as
I would hope they are of mine and he's
undoubtedly the case in Shakespeare you
often learn more about your own
character from what other people say or
do then what he actually gives you to
say but that's life isn't it God the guy
was genius honestly do you realize he
wrote Lear the Scottish play and Antony
and Cleopatra all in the same year and
he was at the end of his life and I have
seen I think was the first to second
folio of Antony Cleopatra because they
did it years ago and there's one full
stop in that script and it's after the
last word of the play one full stop this
guy writing with candlelight and quill
pens Thank You William
yeah you would you talked earlier about
preparing for the play going to swim
going and also when you went as a part
of your when you were in Parliament
visiting the elderly do you identify at
your age now with
Laer know one of the things that I find
fascinating about the length of well my
age is that the me inside hasn't changed
at all I mean I think the me inside is
about 15 years old
it's the envelope that's carrying the me
inside around that simply refuses to do
what I tell it I mean I think is won't
work and you know my back gives me
trouble and I lose my balance and things
like that but and also also them really
you know fascinating thing I find
fascinating is you well I do I'm not
making this is general rule for age I so
where of how much I don't know and I
think my god just ignorant have you got
time to learn laughter wait and see
Benjamin Franklin at the end of his life
gives a famous speech in which he
supports the Constitution he says I
don't agree with it
but I have learned at this age that I
don't know very much despite the fact
everybody thought he was the wisest man
in the room final question what what is
your day like
what is a day like well my day is quite
normal if it's you know a performing day
but I closed the door on worlder two
o'clock and that's getting ready to go
to the theater well no I don't even do
that I mean I put my feet up I tried to
save energy but yep that's the beginning
my working day really at what moment
are you Lear you'd have to ask a member
of the audience for a reply to that
question I'm too busy doing doing it to
know which means you it is a good get
out isn't it that's excellent